Are you a wrestler?
I show you 5 exercises to increase your strength and your
explosiveness!
Let's go!
1st exercise,
the squat front.
The objective here is to strengthen the chain
and to accentuate
1 work on our quadriceps
but also the trunk
by reducing the abdominal strap.
6 to 8 repetitions,
4 sets.
We then follow up with some heavy draw at work,
8s,
4 series.
The objective here is to make prints simultaneously
and therefore increase our speed during our seizures.
Exercise 3 is 1 of my favorites,
deadliffe zershire,
best exercise to improve our slam in grapping.
We will carry out between 8 and 10 repetitions on 4 series.
Do not hesitate to increase the load
when you feel comfortable with the movement.
We will continue with Le Classique,
the PC sled,
working on our supports
on both sides.
4 round trips,
5 sets.
We finish with 1 big cardiovascular work on
15seconds of passive recovery.
We will then follow on 1 big try
over 30seconds
continuously
before resuming 15 seconds of recovery
and reconnect for 30 seconds
of Argentina.
If you liked the video,
don't forget to comment on it,
to share it and subscribe!